zdf heute live herzlich willkommen wer
soll wie lange in quarantäne das wurde
an deutschen schulen bislang sehr
unterschiedlich gehandelt wenn es um
corona ging gehandhabt wenn es um corona
ging jetzt haben sich bund und
gesundheitsministerinnen und minister
geeinigt am frühen abend ist bayerns
gesundheitsminister horaczek vor die
presse getreten und wir hören uns an was
er zu sagen hatte wir waren uns alle
sehr einig dass wir ein großes interesse
haben an einem möglichst verlässlichen
schulunterricht und natürlich auch der
betreuung der kinder in den
kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen
das ist das ziel das über diesen
beschlüssen auch steht und wir haben
damit auch die grundlage glaube ich für
diese beschlüsse gelegt indem wir gesagt
haben möglichst einen guten
infektionsschutz so gut wie möglich auf
der anderen seite so viel
präsenzunterricht wie es auch immer geht
darüber sprechen wir hier heute abend
mit dabei ist der virologe jonas
schmidt-chanasit aus hamburg und sie
wenn sie möchten wir freuen uns über
ihre fragen und kommentare wie immer in
die kommentare oder wenn sie die zdf-
heute- app nutzen an die eingeblendete e
mail adresse
worauf haben sich nun die ministerinnen
und minister konkret geeinigt moritz
neues fasst zusammen
in fast allen bundesländern sind die
sommerferien vorbei doch die pandemie
bleibt auch im neuen schuljahr deshalb
gilt für schülerinnen und schüler
weiterhin maske tragen regelmäßig testen
und klassenzimmer lüften sofern schulen
und kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen die
entsprechenden konzepte an greifen
folgende regeln die von den
gesundheitsministern der länder
beschlossen wurde wird eine schülerin
oder ein schüler positiv getestet so
müssen nur noch die engen
kontaktpersonen in quarantäne nicht mehr
die gesamte schulklasse das sind
diejenigen schülerinnen und schüler
welche unmittelbar und ohne schutz in
kontakt mit infizierten waren zum
beispiel direkte sitznachbarn
anschließend sollen weitere
neuinfektionen innerhalb der klasse bei
schülern die nicht direkte kontakt
personen sind durch ein engmaschiges
test konzept schnellstmöglich erkannt
werden wer in quarantäne muss kann sich
nach fünf tagen via pc oder antigen
schnelltest frei testen lassen schimpfte
und genesene sind von der quarantäne
pflicht ausgenommen
tja und jetzt begrüße ich den
vom bernhard-nocht-institut in hamburg
schönen guten abend
für wie sinnvoll halten sie diese regeln
auf die man sich da heute geeinigt hat
na ja zunächst einmal ist das noch eine
große erleichterung die kinder und
jugendlichen das nicht mehr ganze
klassenverbände in quarantäne müssen und
dann kann man jetzt durchaus in die
details gehen und diskutieren ob es auch
möglich gewesen wäre entsprechende menge
sitznachbarn ohne quarantäne eigentlich
regelmäßig also täglich zu testen um
somit eine quarantäne zu verhindern dass
quasi nur das positiv getestete kind
letztendlich isoliert wird das ist etwas
was man diskutieren kann aber es ist auf
jeden fall ein schritt nach vorne eine
vereinheitlichung dh diese unterschiede
die es bis jetzt zwischen den
bundesländern gegeben hat gibt es in der
zukunft nicht mehr und das ist doch
schon mal gut das was sie gerade
angesprochen haben das wird in baden
württemberg zum beispiel praktiziert
werden wenn die schule dort wieder
losging zumindest war das der plan ob
das jetzt nach dieser regelung heute
noch bestand hat das bleibt abzuwarten
aber bevor wir da in die details gehen
würde ich gerne mal auf eine grafik
blicken die zeigt nämlich den anstieg
der neuinfektionen
wir hier die sieben tage inzidenz
aufgedröselt nach altersgruppen und da
sehen wir in den letzten kalenderwochen
bei dem orangenen balken das sind die 15
bis 29 jährigen einen anstieg auf bis zu
knapp 150 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen und
wenn wir unten hin blicken dann sehen
wir den blauen balken das sind die
älteren also die wahrscheinlich
geimpften altersgruppen wenn sie sich
diesen verlauf angucken dann war doch
abzusehen dass diese entwicklung jetzt
so ist wie sie ist kommt diese
entscheidung der gesundheitsminister
nicht viel zu spät
naja zum einen müssen wir aber auch
erwähnen dass wir natürlich gerade in
den schulen besonders genau hinschauen
was die infektion mit trifft mit den
regelmäßigen gästen zum anderen janssen
erwähnt wir hatten die älteren
erwachsenen eben die möglichkeit sich
impfen zu lassen insofern sicherlich war
das zu erwarten dass die inzidenz in der
altersgruppe höher ist als in den anders
in den anderen altersgruppen aber wir
müssen hier natürlich auch noch mal
deutlich sagen dass die auswirkung einer
infektion im kinder und jugendalter
immer ganz andere sind als wenn sich 80
oder 90 jährige infizieren und das muss
man auch immer noch mal betonen ich
möchte gerne direkt eine frage eines
zuschauers mit reinnehmen die auch auf
die hygieneregeln abzielt die
eingehalten werden müssen auch das haben
die gesundheitsminister noch mal betont
oliver stowasser fragt über e-mail er
ist selber vater von drei kindern wie
sinnvoll ist es schüler in der klasse
bei fest zugewiesenen sitzplätzen jeden
tag eine maske tragen zu lassen obwohl
in jedem restaurant die masken
abgenommen werden dürfen sobald die
gäste sitzen und in clubs und
diskotheken keinen abstand keine maske
mehr benötigt wird und unsere schüler
obendrein alle zwei tage getestet werden
so eine quälerei kann ich nicht
verstehen welches argument gibt es um
das eine zu erlauben und das andere zu
verbieten
das sind politische argumente das kann
ich als wissenschaftler wie gesagt auch
nur sehr schwer erklären das wurde
politisch letztendlich so entschieden
sie sehen ja auch in anderen ländern
dass das zum teil anders gehandhabt wird
arbeit müssen ja auch sagen das kann man
zum teil nicht eins zu eins auf
deutschland übertragen aber in dänemark
ist es zb anders aber großbritannien und
wir müssen jetzt einfach als
gesellschaft diskutieren und ich hoffe
wir machen das wie viel ressourcen und
das wurde eben angesprochen die teste
kosten natürlich geld und auch
personaleinsatz ist letztendlich
notwendig liefe ressourcen wollen wir in
zukunft aufwenden um diese restrisiken
weiter zu reduzieren zumal wir jetzt
eben auch über zwölfjährige die
möglichkeit haben sich impfen zu lassen
insofern wird man auch in diesen
altersgruppen die sehr geringen risiken
für erkrankungen oder schwere verläufe
ja noch weiter reduzieren mit der
impfungen dann muss man sich irgendwann
die frage stellen wie lange man diese
maßnahmen diese einschränkenden
maßnahmen aufrecht erhalten will sie
haben der bild am sonntag gesagt wenn
bei verhältnismäßig niedrigen instanzen
schulkinder dreimal pro woche getestet
werden kann dass 200.000 euro kosten um
ein einziges positives aber symptomfrei
ist kind ausfindig zu machen das wäre
also quasi eine argumentation gegen mehr
testen aus finanziellen gründen
nein so einfach ist es nicht es geht
darum systematisch zu testen sinnvoll zu
testen das heißt eine breite massen
testung mit schnell testen ist
sicherlich in dem umfang bei einer
niedrigen incidents fraglich ich hatte
es ja nun angesprochen was dort für
kosten entstehen und wir haben ja auch
noch andere gesundheitsrisiken auch bei
kindern und da muss man sich einfach die
frage stellen wo setzen wir die
begrenzten ressourcen die wir in
deutschland haben geschickt ein um die
gesundheit der kinder zu erhalten und zu
verbessern und das ist eine frage die
wir als gesellschaft eben beantworten
müssen und natürlich und ich habe jetzt
einen erwähnen sind test ein ganz
wichtiges hilfsmittel
gerade wenn ein fall auftritt ist der pc
zum beispiel als lolli test gegen ja der
ja auch schon eben eingesetzt wird in
verschiedenen bundesländern durchaus
geeignet um die sozusagen teilhabe der
kinder am unterricht weiter zu
gewährleisten und sicher zu
gewährleisten weil ich ihr mit einem
regelmäßigen in dem fall täglichen
pcr-test ausschließen kann dass sie
effektiv sind also teste sind ganz
wichtig man muss sich aber nur richtig
einsetzen vor allem an der richtigen
stelle dann würde mich interessieren ob
sie da derselben meinung sind wie karl
lauterbach der spd gesundheitsexperte
der sich uns gegenüber auch zum thema
testen geäußert hat und
schauen wir uns gemeinsam an die
beschlüsse der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz kann dann
umsetzen damit kann man arbeiten besser
hätte ich es gefunden wir werden zu
einer regelung gekommen dass die
quarantäne noch stärker also
eingeschränkt worden wäre zum beispiel
indem das kind oder wenn ein kind
infiziert ist dieses kind nach hause
geht und in den folgenden fünf tagen
dann alle kinder in der schulklasse
jeden tag mit einem schnelltest getestet
werden damit könnte man mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit die also
infektionswelle in dieser schule und in
dieser klasse brechen ohne dass es
übermäßig viele quarantäne fälle gäbe
ist dass das was sie mit sinnvollen
testen gemeint haben oder meinen sie da
was unterschiedlich ist nein das ist ein
gutes beispiel was karl lauterbach
erwähnt hat dass wir einfach quarantäne
verhindern dass die kinder weiter am
unterricht teilnehmen können und in
dieser spezifischen situationen macht
das durchaus sinn auch mit den schnell
testens arbeiten natürlich
professionell eingesetzt überwacht
qualitätsgesichert das ist immer ganz
wichtig bei den schnell testen bei der
pca ist es ja so und so der fall
insofern kann man sich dann auch nochmal
darüber kann man diskutieren was
letztendlich denn auch finanziell
günstiger als ob man zum beispiel
sogenannte pool testung macht das ist ja
nur mit dem pc attesten möglich mit den
lolli testen also da gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche ideen aber letztendlich
sind beide varianten ok schnelltest
täglich oder wie gesagt die pcr test
dann würde ich gerne noch auf einen
punkt an gehen den der vater gerade
angesprochen hat nämlich das maske
tragen wie wichtig ist aus ihrer sicht
das maske tragen in der schule in dieser
phase
das muss sich sicherlich am
infektionsgeschehen im orientieren das
heißt wenn wir einen großen
infektionsdruck haben von außen auch die
schulen das ist ja mal das problem dass
die infektion von außen in die schulen
getragen werden sagen wir jetzt mal eine
inzidenz von 800 oder 900 dann kann das
in solchen kritischen situationen
durchaus sinnvoll sein in bestimmten
bereichen wo also eine infektionsgefahr
entsteht auch masken zu tragen in
niedrig incident zeiten kann man sich
sicherlich überlegen ob man das so
flächendeckend in allen bereichen machen
also auch hier gilt eine risiko
adaptierte strategie die maßnahmen
müssen natürlich angepasst werden und
das betrifft auch die masken
ein einwurf von feierabend 1 über
youtube die ganze situation mutet
konzeptlos an wir haben den anstieg der
zahlen gerade gesehen hätten sie sich
auch gewünscht ich weiß das ist zwar
wieder eine politische frage an
virologen das ist immer fies aber da
haben wir uns jetzt in diesen zeiten
auch daran gewöhnen müssen
warum gibt es dafür kein konzept warum
kommen die gesundheitsminister heute wo
berlin schon seit mehr als vier wochen
wieder in der schule ist macht sie das
als virologen auch gewissermaßen fertig
naja natürlich kann man sich fragen ob
man diese politischen entscheidungen auf
einer besseren datengrundlage hätte
treffen können und das natürlich
langfristig aber da kommen wir
letztendlich zu dem hauptproblem wir
haben einen datenerhebung problem in
deutschland das betrifft nicht nur die
schulen das betrifft auch andere
bereiche zb viele menschen sind denn
jetzt wirklich gekämpft in deutschland
ist eine ganz wichtige zahl aber da gibt
es probleme und wenn wir nach
großbritannien schauen da sind die daten
wie sie erhoben werden wie sie vorhanden
sind und dann auch eine grundlage für
politische entscheidungen darstellen
viel viel besser das ist ein
grundproblem und ich hoffe dass wir das
ist eine wichtige lehre aus der pandemie
dass wir das mitnehmen dass wir das auf
jeden fall verbessern in der zukunft
aber genau dadurch kommt es letztendlich
auch zu so irakischen politischen
entscheidungen weil die datengrundlage
die sicherheit ist die schnell verändert
und letztendlich eine gute verlässliche
politische entscheidungen zum teil nicht
zulässt dann schauen wir mal gemeinsam
auf daten die vor liegen nämlich die
zahlen der infizierten kinder dazu gibt
es eine seite die erfasst wie die zahlen
unterschiedlich auf die altersgruppen
verteilt sind wenn wir jetzt sehen das
ist die deutschlandkarte
aufgeteilt auf alle altersgruppen von 0
bis 80 plus und hier sehen wir einige
grüne und hellgelbe bereiche vor allem
im osten der republik
und dem westen sehen wir einige die sind
rot das heißt sie haben eine inzidenz
von 100 bis 200 wenn man jetzt die
altersgruppe der 0
5 bis 14 jährigen anklickt dann stellt
man fest diese karte verändert sich
radikal schnell und wir sehen in vielen
gebieten der inzidenz von 200 bis 500
das heißt also wir sehen dass diese
altersgruppe im moment besonders stark
betroffen ist und das führt wiederum zu
der frage zurück wie gefährdet sind denn
kinder in ihren augen überhaupt
naja diese karte trübt natürlich man
muss ja sagen die kinder kommen wieder
in die schule in nrw zum beispiel werden
dort dann das erste mal getestet und
stehen natürlich die zahlen nach oben
das heißt ja nicht dass sie sich in der
schule infiziert haben sondern dass sie
die infektion mitgebracht haben nämlich
nach der reisezeit das heißt die
infektion finden in einem anderen raum
statt wo sie nicht so gut geschützt sind
das ist die entscheidende sage ich mal
das was man aus dieser karte mitnehmen
sollte das heißt wir haben sehr gute
sehr viele maßnahmen in den schulen die
infektionen vermeiden es gibt keine
riesigen massenhaften schul ausbrüche
das muss man auch noch mal betonen das
zeigen ja die daten der letzten monate
weil natürlich maßnahme ergriffen boden
und man kann sich jetzt wünschen dass
man so eben auch durch den herbst geht
mit den entsprechenden
sicherheitsmaßnahmen die auch durch die
vielen wissenschaftlichen
fachgesellschaften ja empfohlen werden
also wir haben das lüften angesprochen
wir haben das maske neben in bestimmten
situation bei hohen infektionsdruck auch
angesprochen also da gibt es ja neben
den impfungen jetzt eben auch möglich
sind ab 12 jahre viele möglichkeiten die
kinder zu schützen das heißt sie nehmen
eltern die angst ihre kinder in die
schule zu schicken verstehe ich das
richtig
ja was ist denn die konsequenz die
kinder nicht in die schule zu schicken
hat fatale folgen das ist eindeutig so
festgestellt worden durch die
weltgesundheitsorganisation
durch die unicef durch die kinderärzte
durch die wissenschaftlichen
fachgesellschaften in deutschland also
das schlimmste was wir machen können ist
die kinder nicht in die schule zu
schicken nicht in die kita zu schicken
das ist glaube ich was ganz deutlich
geworden und dieser pandemie was ist mit
der gefahr schwer zu erkranken auch
schwere verläufe gibt es bei kindern es
gibt das pimps syndrom es gibt longo
witt in der abwägung all dessen was sie
sehen würden sie sagen trotzdem sind die
schulen so wie sie im moment aufgestellt
sind immer noch ein sicherer ort und es
ist gut dorthin zu gehen wenn wir uns
die zahlen anschauen die durch die
kinderärzte eben erhoben werden und die
sind wirklich sehr gut sehr belastbar
dann sehen wir dort das zumindestens in
den letzten anderthalb jahren nichts
dramatisches passiert ist dass wir keine
dramatische zunahme haben dass nach wie
vor die aussage richtig ist kinder
jugendliche erkranken sehr sehr sehr
selten sehr schwer und das ist ganz
wichtig eine wichtige informationen für
die eltern das heißt man kann zum einen
mit der impfung das geringe risiko was
kinder sohn zu haben noch weiter
reduzieren aber man muss sich
prinzipiell keine großen sorgen machen
wenn ich das kind in die schule schicken
ist es doch zu einer infektion kommen
sollte egal ob jetzt in der schule
erworben wurde oder außerhalb der schule
wahrscheinlich eher außerhalb der schule
dann muss ich davor erstmal prinzipiell
keine große angst
das betrifft natürlich erstmal gesunde
kinder eine andere kategorie sind kinder
mit vorerkrankungen das ist ein
besonderes gebiet wo wir uns auch
gedanken machen können oder müssen wie
wir kinder die noch nicht geimpft werden
kann also die unter zwölfjährigen mit
vor kann und wie wir die eben auch
schützen das sind besondere
fragestellungen die auch mit den kinder
ärzten diskutiert werden aber wie gesagt
die mehrzahl der kinder und das zeigen
die daten der kinderärzte erkranken
nicht schwer und longo wird ist eine
wichtige frage aber nach anderthalb
jahren sehen wir auch bisher dass das
kein gravierendes großes problem bei
kinder und jugendlichen ist das kann
sich natürlich in den nächsten jahren
kann sich auch etwas ändern das kann
sichtbar werden untersuchungen dazu
laufen jahr ist auch wichtig dass das
untersucht wird aber rückblickend und
von den daten und oder mit denen daten
müssen wir arbeiten können wir nur sagen
bisher ist das auch kein gravierendes
großes phänomen bei kinder und
jugendlichen longo fit
was ist mit der schule als ansteckung
sword können nicht kinder die sich in
der schule infizieren das virus weiter
geben und dann ihre eltern und andere
altersgruppen anstecken
ja das ist natürlich möglich nur wenn
wir jetzt auch wieder rückschauend eben
die situation in deutschland betrachten
es ist in den meisten fällen so gewesen
dass infektionen in die schulen hinein
getragen wo zum beispiel durch lehrer
und erzieher und dass kinder immer
endpunkte oder meist endpunkte der
infektionsketten gewesen sind und nicht
ausgangspunkt und nicht super sprecher
das ist nochmal ganz wichtig das heißt
nicht dass kinder auch mal übertragen
können das geht natürlich auch aber in
der mehrzahl der fälle ist der weg eben
andersherum gewesen
alfons von zwiebel schöner name fragt
über facebook was ist mit den
luftfiltern wand findet endlich ein
flächendeckender einsatz statt es gibt
doch ausreichend studien die eine
unterstützte wirkung nachgewiesen haben
aus biologischer sicht wie gut wäre es
wenn alle deutschen schulen mit
luftfiltern ausgestattet werden was sie
nicht sind
ja das ist eine frage die auch intensiv
diskutiert wurde zwischen den
unterschiedlichen wissenschaftlichen
fachgesellschaften primär versucht man
erst mal eben zu lüften und das ist
eigentlich ausreichend ich verstehe aber
auch dass es im winter natürlich
schwieriger wird nur man muss bei den
luftfiltern wissen wenn sie nicht
richtig verwendet werden wenn sie nicht
richtig eingebaut sind kann es sogar
dazu kommen dass das infektionsrisiko
erhöht wird insofern müssen da auch
spezialisten ran es gibt auch
entsprechende vorschläge auch vom
max-planck-institut wie man
solche einrichtungen richtig installiert
in den klassenräumen aber ich wäre da
etwas zurückhaltender pauschal diese
forderung aufzustellen es gibt
sicherlich klassenräume wo eine gute
durchlüftung nicht möglich ist dort kann
es eine lösung sein mit den luftfiltern
zu arbeiten aber im regelfall sollte man
erstmal auf die durchlüftung setzen und
das ist auch ausreichend um aerosol
konzentration zu ändern viel wichtiger
und nachhaltiger als im co2 ampeln das
ist entscheidend dass man sieht wie ist
denn die belastung und das ist nicht nur
für corona wichtig sondern auch in der
zukunft das eben die luftqualität gut
ist also das ist sicherlich eine sehr
sinnvolle maßnahme co2 amt in jedem
klassenraum aber von der ampel wird die
luft nicht besser
von der ampel wird die luft nicht besser
aber ich weiß wie ich die luft besser
machen kann nämlich durch lüften und wie
gesagt wenn das eben gegen klassenräumen
wo das nicht möglich ist wird das schwer
möglich ist da können luft wird er
sicherlich eine alternative sein wie
gesagt eigentlich ganz einfaches thema
ich möchte es jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
sagen dass das jetzt das letzte wort ist
aber man muss bedenken dass es hier
natürlich auch um nachhaltige maßnahmen
gehen sollte luftfilter sind dann auch
wartungsintensiv müssen ausgewechselt
werden natürlich auch eine gewisse
geräuschkulisse also ich will nicht
sagen dass es nicht sinnvoll ist aber es
ist eben auch nicht so einfach wie man
sich das vielleicht immer vorstellt dass
man jetzt einfach überall luftfilter
einstellt und dann ist alles gut so
einfach übersehen wir erleben in der
diskussion es gibt viele eltern die sind
einfach sauer weil sie sagen nach so
vielen monaten pandemie ist dem staat
nicht viel eingefallen um unsere
kleinsten zu schützen man kann sie nicht
impfen was uns bleibt ist lüften gerade
angesprochen händewaschen und es ist
schwer zu akzeptieren dass diese so
scheinbar banalen maßnahmen das einzige
mittel sein sollen und können um gegen
die pandemie auch bei den kleinen zu
kämpfen einer dieser mütter ist michaela
strehlke die sagt über facebook jedes
kind das krank wird ist eines zu viel
durchseuchung findet in der schule statt
händewaschen ist keine maßnahme des
virus überträgt sich nicht über die
hände aero sohle die schulen sind nicht
sicher was antworten sie da
ja das kann man natürlich nur im
direkten persönlichen gespräch auch auf
die sorgen ängste der eltern eingehen
und ich kann das absolut nachvollziehen
aber
nochmal ich möchte hier auch der mutter
sagen das was uns die kinderärzte zeigen
an guten daten zeigt dass kinder eben im
regelfall nicht schwer kranken das long
kurve so lange jetzt schon sozusagen
zurückschauen können keine große rolle
bei den kindern spielt insofern muss man
sich die frage stellen in welchem
verhältnis steht das duo anderen
gesundheitsrisiken die kinder
ausgesetzt in den kindern ausgesetzt
sind und dass ist eine diskussion die
wir als gesellschaft führen müssen ich
will da gar keine antwort darauf geben
ich stelle einfach nur die frage und
wenn sich die gesellschaft dafür
entscheidet dass es eben richtig ist
jede corona virusinfektion überall immer
zu verhindern dann ist das die
entscheidung zu der wir hier in
deutschland gekommen sind wenn man sagt
es gibt andere risiken die vielleicht
größer sind und wir wollen die
ressourcen dafür verwenden dann ist das
auch eine entscheidung über leben muss
und man muss ja wie gesagt auch in die
anderen länder schauen das heißt nicht
dass man das 1 1 übernehmen soll aber
die anderen länder haben sich eben zum
teil so entschieden dass man sagt die
kinder können ohne maßnahmen in die
schulen
sehr individuell sind die meinungen bei
eltern und schülern in diesem thema
paula kolberg hat sich heute in mainz in
der fußgängerzone umgehört und das hier
mitgebracht zurzeit ist das ja so dass
die sitz
pläne ja ganz fest stehen also ich finde
das sehr gut und ich denke wenn sich
alle daran halten könnten dann denke ich
schon dass nur die sitznachbarn in
quarantäne könnten halt mit test und so
aber da das leider in den meisten
schulen nicht der fall ist dass sich die
schüler daran halten können denke schon
dass es richtig ist wenn alle in
quarantäne gehen sollten eine gesamte
schulklasse ehren nicht spezifisch es
gibt immer sitz plänen oder sowas und
sich halt daran orientieren das glaube
ich dass ängste ich finde das denn die
ganze klasse in quarantäne sollte weil
sonst würden sie sich anstecken falls
sich jetzt schon mal jemand angesteckt
hat und ich glaube bei den ganzen
maßnahmen die sie heutzutage treffen mit
dem lüften und diesen geräten diese
ihren klassenzimmern haben würde ich
sagen rechtsschutz mittlerweile dass die
drum umsitzenden mit denen sie mehr
kontakt haben in quarantäne gehen
tja also sehr unterschiedliche meinungen
zum thema interessant dass der jüngste
teilnehmer ausgerechnet sagt er am
besten sollte die ganze klasse in
quarantäne
das bringt mich zu der frage die
gesundheitsminister haben gesagt die
gesundheitsämter sollen mit augenmaß
entscheiden das bedeutet natürlich die
politik hat heute leitplanken geregelt
aber innerhalb derer gibt es wird es
immer noch total individuelle
entscheidungen geben und vielleicht auch
manche eltern und kinder frustriert sein
weil man dann doch nicht nachvollziehen
kann warum im einzelfall so entschieden
wurde wer wenn die zahlen im herbst
nochmal steigen soll das denn alles
leisten dieses augenmaß denn das
bedeutet ja dass in den
gesundheitsämtern genügend wache augen
vorhanden sind um maß zu nehmen und zu
gucken was ist denn im einzelfall
überhaupt passiert und wer muss in
quarantäne
das verlagert die verantwortlichkeit
ganz weit nach unten in die ämter und
auch zu den schulleitungen und die
werden doch in absehbarer zeit an ihre
grenzen kommen
absolut das war auch schon in der
vergangenheit so und das wird sich
leider auch in der zukunft nicht ändern
da muss man eben daran arbeiten dass das
in der zukunft besser wird dass es fast
alles was ich dazu sagen kann aber ich
muss auch noch mal sagen wir haben jetzt
fast eine halbe stunde über die schulen
und kitas gesprochen das ist auch
richtig ist ein wichtiges thema aber das
was wirklich problematisch wird im
herbst und winter wie im letzten herbst
und winter das sind die alten und
pflegeheime und da reden wir fast
überhaupt nicht darüber das heißt wenn
wir jetzt über ressourcen sprechen die
in den gesundheitsämtern vorhanden sind
die sehr begrenzt sind dann wäre es
sicherlich sinnvoll diese wenigen
ressourcen für ausbrüche in
krankenhäusern altenpflege einmal
einzusetzen weil dort wird es auch
wieder zu infektionen kommen weil die
wirkung der impfstoffe eben gerade bei
den älteren die nicht so eine starke
immunantwort bilden können nachlassen
wird und dort sind die infektion eben
wirklich ein problem weil dort eben sehr
viele daran versterben können und das
ist der große unterschied zu schulen und
kita wobei man davon ausgehen kann dass
man titel bestimmen kann und dass man
dritt impfen kann und damit schwere
verläufe verhindern zumindest ist das
der plan gewesen oder
das ist der plan gewesen ich hoffe dass
das umgesetzt wird auch gut umgesetzt
wird aber es ging ja noch mal um die
ressourcen der gesundheitsämter bei
ausbrüchen und
es wird im herbst auch wieder ausbrüche
in pflegen in pflegeheimen altenheim und
auch in krankenhäusern geben wenn man da
nicht ganz genau hingeguckt und wenn man
jetzt eben über prioritäten spricht dann
sind ganz klar die prioritäten dort wo
wirklich menschen schwere tödliche
verläufe erleiden können eben auch ein
größerer zahl und das sind nun mal diese
einrichtung insofern werden die
gesundheitsämter gefordert sei natürlich
auch in den schulen kitas und ich
wünsche mir natürlich dass die
gesundheitsämter ein schulbetrieb
sicherstellen können dass man eben so
weit es geht viel testet um eben den
regelbetrieb aufrecht zu halten und eben
nicht mehr dazu kommen ganze
klassenverbände in quarantäne zu
schicken dass wir sicherlich sehr sehr
bedauerlich für viele schülerinnen und
schüler
sagt der virologe professor jonas
schmidt-chanasit vielen dank dass sie
sich die zeit genommen haben heute abend
dankeschön und vielleicht bis zum
nächsten mal sehr gerne wieder von
unserer seite und ihnen zu hause auch
ganz vielen herzlichen dank fürs
mitmachen mit diskutieren und fragen
stellen einen schönen abend und bis bald